Is my screen visible?
Yes ma'am.
Okay fine.
So first of all, what we have to do is
the part of discussion today
will be transport setup
and the concession groups
which are created in the system.
This is your interface, login
system.
So first of all
whenever we have to do
transport setup, where is our
basic transport setup option?
Let's see, basic transport setup.
What do you have?
Here are the settings.
You must have noticed
that our basic setup is
in the settings icon.
They depend on which
section you are doing
and they will access that section and do the basic setup.
What we have to do today is the basic setup of transport.
What will be in the basic setup of transport?
For example, there is an institute.
Which buses are there in that institute?
Which pick up points are being considered in that bus?
Like there is a bus
which bus goes to which pick up points?
Where are the drop points of the student?
So that data
which we are managing
which pick up point is assigned to a student
which drop point is assigned to a student
which bus is assigned to a student.
To do that, we have to give a basic configuration
to the system.
Like this is the number of buses in the institute.
These are the points in each bus.
These are the charges in the bus
which we will set up basically.
The point is clear. What do we have to discuss?
Bhavya Tanvi.
Yes ma'am.
So how will we do it?
You have the option to set up the institute.
In this we have
an option of transport.
Whatever is the basic setup of transport
the first level setup of every session
we do it from here.
Remember one more thing.
The transport is
session dependent.
Session dependent means what?
Can anyone tell us?
Session dependent is the transport.
Session dependent.
Like session wise
like if we switch the session
then
means
the students' promote
whatever we have to set up
they are session dependent.
Ok.
Bhavya, do you know the meaning of session dependent?
Yes ma'am.
Session dependent means
very simple.
Like every session
the setup will be different.
So we will call it session dependent.
So you will go to transport.
Here you have the option.
First is vehicle.
Then there is vehicle route.
In that institute
the number of buses
the detail of each bus
is your vehicle.
You will click on it.
Ok.
Here you have the super option.
New vehicle.
I know I have this entity.
Bus 1, bus 2, bus 3
I have the details of their RC numbers.
So how to add a bus?
You will click on new vehicle.
Then you have a window open.
What is this for?
The entries of the bus
are the details.
You have to enter the details of the bus.
First comes RC number.
Like HR 0123
is the number.
You can enter that.
I am putting a simple one.
Then after that
how many seating capacity is there in this bus?
Like 50 seating capacity,
50 seats, 80 seats, 100 seats.
Total seats.
Then your tank capacity.
This is not mandatory.
Full tank capacity, GPS ID.
This is for GPS tracking.
We provide a facility
like this.
I am giving you a brief introduction.
What facility is that?
In which it is used.
We provide an option
like GPS track option.
Means student epic.
QR code kind of.
It will scan the child.
It will get the attendance of the child.
We provide an option of GPS tracker.
GPS is in the bus.
It puts the ID here.
It is not mandatory.
This is your mandatory field.
RC number, your seating capacity.
Then its insurance date,
amount of insurance company.
Rest is your non-mandatory
information.
The corresponding information
of the vehicle.
This is your information.
If you start adding this
it will give you the mandatory information.
Insurance date.
Like I am taking this for now.
For example
the insurance of this bus
is from 2 to 8.
Then the insurance date will come.
After that if you have a corresponding document
you can update it.
Same pollution certificate,
fitness certificate, road permit, road tax.
So we have a vehicle
corresponding mandatory information and documents.
We save that in the data.
Clear?
Now I am just adding
random data.
Here you will get the option
to add the vehicle.
In the same way you can
create N number of vehicles in the system.
You have added the vehicle
Still you have to update it.
You can do this.
You have to update
more information.
You have the option
to update the detail.
You can update the existing detail as well.
Then you have the option
to update the data.
Any doubts?
No ma'am.
Is it clear?
One minute.
Ok.
Let's continue.
Is this part clear?
Yes ma'am.
This is your vehicle
that you add.
You can add bus 1 and bus 2.
Now
what we have done is
we have added the data
of buses in the transport
institute.
Now in that bus
where the bus is going,
where it drops the students,
where it picks them,
all that is our vehicle route.
Do you understand the route?
The whole route of a bus
is defined in the system
in the vehicle route.
Ok.
How do we create this?
You have the option
of new vehicle route, copy from session
and then exit.
What option do we have?
It is possible that
there are many entities
that are running from the previous session.
Ok.
The previous session
means
that the previous session
has the same data.
It means that you have to copy
from the previous session.
So we can use this feature
which is the button
to copy from the previous session.
This will be used
because you will have a session list.
This entity has a single session.
If it had only 24-25 entities,
it would have come in the drop-down.
If I had selected that,
the set-up of the vehicle route
would have been copied from the previous session.
Do you understand the purpose of this?
Yes ma'am.
We have also done the BAP module
in the basic set-up,
copy from the previous session.
Yes, so you can copy from the previous session
if you have any previous
already existing entity.
Now I have a new entity
in which I have to add the vehicle route.
What is this Excel?
The data that you have here
is to export that data in Excel.
We will add a new vehicle route.
You have the option
to add it.
Now you have to add the name of the route.
For example,
I have added route 1.
Which vehicle is running on the first route?
The whole list will come here.
The data that I will give you
if you create N number of vehicles,
the whole list will come here.
You can set the route according to yourself.
Like the bus that runs on route 1,
which bus runs,
I have selected that vehicle.
Then,
you have to understand
what this means.
In the case of school,
installments are made
in case it is monthly.
You must have seen it in your fee structure.
In case it is not monthly,
it is bi-monthly.
For example,
there is one for 6 months.
It will be from April to June.
It will be for 6 months.
So all the installments are made.
So this is what we have.
Now,
you have to add pickup points.
To add pickup points
this Buss.
This bus that runs on route 1,
this bus, like,
that goes to Ansaal,
it goes to Taiseel camp,
there are pickup points.
For example, it is Ansaal's pickup point.
All the pickup points are different.
But,
whatever installments are made,
in this installment, the fees will not be charged.
You might know this in the case of schools.
In the case of schools, we do not take the fees for the transport in the month of June,
nor do we assign the fees to the children in demand.
The fees for the transport in the month of June are not there.
So, what will happen here?
All the installments will come in April to March.
So, in that case, you will select the installments here.
And then what is he doing?
After selecting that, he is defining in the setup
that whatever fees we will pay here,
the fees will not be charged in the selected installment.
Do you understand?
What is the purpose of this?
Select skip installment.
We have to skip the transport amount for the selected particular installment.
Ma'am, we can select multiple months at a time.
Exactly.
We can select for the first and second installment.
But this means that he will skip.
Selecting means that he will not pay the fees for that particular installment.
Okay.
We do this in the case of schools, most probably.
If we select the month of June,
then when we assign a particular pick-up point to the student,
then in that case, the fees will be charged from April to March.
It will not be charged in June because we have selected the month of June.
This is the main agenda.
Then we have the select employee.
Now, you can also assign the driver of this bus.
You can assign more than one if you want.
Now, where does this data come from?
It comes from the employee.
In our setup, you have not seen the basic employee of HRM.
Have you seen how the employees are added?
No, ma'am.
Okay.
So now when you see it, you will know.
Basic employees are added.
Either teaching, non-teaching, driver, daily wages,
whatever.
So we save that data.
So that comes to the employee.
Means this is the driver of the bus.
Its list comes.
The list is created in your system.
Okay.
Is it clear?
Yes, ma'am.
Okay.
Then now we have the pick-up point.
Like I have this bus.
Okay.
Inside this bus,
where does this bus go?
On the side of the institute,
we have complete data in an excel format.
Okay.
If we have complete data,
it will be written that in route 1,
this vehicle runs.
And the vehicle running in route 1,
what are the pick-up points?
I will say Ansel.
Okay.
If Ansel has a pick-up point,
what is the pick-up time?
What is the drop time?
Like this bus that is running,
at what time does this bus reach Ansel?
At what time does it drop the students at Ansel?
Okay.
That is the timing.
For example,
I put it at 6 o'clock.
6 am.
Okay.
And what is the drop point?
4 pm.
Okay.
So, this is the pick-up time
and drop point.
There will be a drop time.
Okay.
Then after that,
you have the amount.
Longitude and latitude are not mandatory.
In which case does this work?
I will tell you.
Our GPS tracking system works.
Okay.
So, we put the longitude and latitude of the bus.
It is of Google Maps.
I mean,
there is no use case now.
You will know gradually.
Okay.
Basically,
we put this.
Then its amount,
its corresponding Ansel route,
how much is the amount?
For example,
2000.
Okay.
So, this is 2000.
Similarly,
add another pick-up point.
your number of pick-up points
can be added.
Now,
we will add one.
You will add.
As soon as you add,
it will be created in the system.
Okay.
This option,
this was the option
to add manually the pick-up route.
In the pick-up route,
all the pick-up points are there.
One pick-up point has been added.
That is why it is being made here.
If you add more than one,
it will be more than one.
Is that okay?
Let's go ahead.
There are more options in this.
Yes, ma'am.
Okay.
Now,
you have added it once.
But,
it can be done later.
we need to add more pick-up points to it.
In that case,
same option for adding is there.
You will add,
it will open the interface.
You will add another one according to your choice.
It will update.
Yes?
You mean,
we can add multiple points?
Yes, exactly.
n number of points here.
Okay.
One is done,
then you will add pick-pick,
and then add another one.
Okay.
That is.
This was our
option to add manually.
This means,
can the rock buttons by use that can manually add value then a
option of the bulk may be updated via Excel.
Upload pick up point.
Pick up point.
Root.
Kind of.
Pick up point.
Sample Excel.
Pick up.
Pick up point.
Excel.
Save.
Pick up.
Excel.
data via Excel.
Okay.
basic transport setup.
That is concession books.
That is concessions.
concession.
Yes, sir.
You can add a new concession in the system.
You have the option to add a new concession group.
How does this work?
Whatever fee you have defined in the system,
and the corresponding installments.
Because your entire fee structure is going according to the installments.
Even the concession will not go according to the installments.
Like if your fee is tuition fee, tuition fee is 4 installments,
then the concession will also be tuition fee.
It will go according to 4 installments.
Right?
Yes.
For example,
I am making a concession.
I am making a staff card concession.
Here you will define the name of the concession,
the job concession you are creating.
Then the concession that is being created,
which fee head is being created?
There is an option,
everyone's fee head is being created.
One fee head is being created.
You will select according to yourself.
For example, the staff card concession,
their annual fees are being created.
They have said that they have a 50% concession.
Like all the fees,
the complete fees is 50%.
So there are two options,
percentage and flat.
I talked about 50%
so I will use percentage.
And here I will list the percentage value.
Like in all the installments,
it is 50%.
So I did 50 here.
In case the concession is not in the percentage,
that is it is in the flat.
Flat means that there are 5000 concessions.
For first installment only.
There is no concession on anyone else.
So you can flat according to yourself
and put that value.
It is clear,
if you add normal to create concession group,
your concession group will be added.
This is done.
In the system,
staff card concession,
sibling concession,
whatever is their criteria,
on the basis of that criteria,
your concession can be done.
Ma'am,
in this system,
by default,
this name,
like staff board,
we have typed it ourselves.
So by default,
all concessions,
whatever is available,
will come by default,
when you assign concession.
For example,
when I assign concession to a student,
then that list will come to me,
that in the system,
which ones are made for the institute.
Now,
the name of every entity is very different.
Okay?
Okay.
So in that case,
when will this come?
We are defining it now.
What you are saying now,
that it is listed,
we are defining it now.
When the student will be assigned,
then they will come,
for a drop down.
One more thing,
most of the time,
we also do manual concessions.
You must have seen one thing,
many times,
such concessions are given,
like the principal said,
give me 5,000.
Okay?
So that is our manual concession,
that we can give at any cost.
Our means,
it is the institute's will,
that your fee is clear,
that we can give at any cost.
So such a concession is also called
manual concession.
Okay?
I mean,
it is used in most of the entities,
so I am telling you,
by doing manual concessions.
In the case of manual concessions,
we keep all the head sticks,
and we do it flat,
and we do it zero.
Why do we do this?
Because this is a concession group,
in which you don't know,
when and how much concession
you have to give to a student.
Okay?
This,
your fee is clear,
or any person concerned,
in the institute,
according to their criteria,
according to them,
a student will be assigned.
So in that case,
we also make a manual concession.
Okay?
When this happens,
when it is not defined,
they have to give concessions,
but this is not defined,
how much concession they have to give.
That varies in every student's case.
Then manual concessions are used.
Thank you.
I will also tell you how to apply.
Where can it be applied?
You have a student.
This is the student's list.
Okay?
You will click on the student list.
Here you have the concession fee.
Okay?
You will click on this.
Okay.
Transport is also from here.
I will also tell you that.
Now the system in which you have created concessions,
you will have the list of concessions.
What you were saying,
Kanvi.
Yes.
For example,
I have to give a manual concession.
Okay?
So in the case of manual concessions,
what is happening?
Here,
it is auto-tick,
it has done annual fee.
Why?
I had done all the tics.
Because if you look at the demand of the fee,
it is only in the annual fees.
If it is not there,
then the concession will not be given.
Right?
When the concession will be given,
the amount will be given.
Now here,
you have the option,
it is editable for you.
Means,
you can give as much concessions as you want.
We call that a manual concession.
Whatever remark you want to enter,
you will enter a remark.
And there is an option,
we can upload a file from here.
Like you must have seen,
there is an application at many places,
there is a signature on the application,
it is written on it.
So that document.
Okay?
We can upload that in the system,
in the corresponding of this particular student.
You will save it,
it will be saved.
Here,
you are asking for the same confirmation
that we have already received this.
Okay?
Look,
For example,
your fees were 10,000.
Out of those 10,000,
you have also deposited 10,000.
So,
your balance will be zero.
But still,
you are giving concessions.
So,
the money in that child
will be shown in the extra fee
or something like that.
Okay?
Here,
you will save the normal,
your concession will be given.
Just for the sake of it.
Okay?
This is our concession
assignment option.
Apart from that,
there will be a staff ward.
For example,
in the case of staff ward,
whatever percentage
I had fixed,
it was automatically
taken as much as I had to give.
5,000,
yes,
5,000 flat fixed.
Okay?
5,000,
it has automatically
fixed 5,000 flat here.
Okay?
you can see one more thing.
Here,
there is also an option
for an enter amount
by pushing.
For example,
we have here
multiple of heads selected.
Okay?
And there is manual concession.
In the case of
manual concession,
we have to give
3,000 concessions.
3,000 concessions,
if you push,
it will see
your headwise.
In this head,
as much as
you are getting
for example,
in this head,
the margin
was 2,000.
The margin of 2,000
means that
your demand
was up to 2,000.
So,
it will give
2,000 concessions.
It cannot give
Do you understand?
Yes.
Okay?
it will give
2,000.
Next head
will give
1,000.
In case of manual.
Okay?
we can assign
a bus
to a student
manually.
Okay?
we will do that.
In case of
student profiles,
the student
interface
you will click on
assign route
then you will
have a pop-up
window
opened.
What is this?
To assign.
Like
which bus is
route.
We have created
Okay?
Which pickup point
is it?
Pickup point.
And after that,
its amount.
Here,
automatically
it has
fetched the amount.
Okay?
The drop point
is also the same.
Select
different route
you will
toggle on
then it will give you
the option.
If it is the same,
it will show the same.
Okay?
You will select
all installments.
Okay?
You will assign
then it will
be assigned.
Here,
Chetan has been
assigned route
successfully.
Means,
it has been assigned
Now, if you
see here,
then it has
been assigned
If you see here,
even in its demand,
transport will be
So,
in the second
and third
installments,
it will be
assigned.
It is clear
how we
have assigned
We have
assigned
pickup point
and route.
The amount
its corresponding
system will
automatically
in your
demand.
will be
transferred.
We cannot
assign
in bulk.
every student
will have
a particular
route.
We can do it
in bulk.
We have
seen
an option
in
transport.
We can
assign it in bulk.
We
use it in bulk.
Do you know
we have?
The students
in the previous
section
upcoming
session
may be
most of
cases
are the
In the
previous
session,
we
export
the
reports.
We
have
the
transport
report